wie schmeckt das Essen in der Business
Class dafür muss man erstmal Business
Class fliegen was ich bis vor diesem
Video noch nie gemacht habe in meinem
Leben ich befinde mich gerade in Amerika
und ich bin in der Business Class nach
Amerika geflogen und ich kann so viel
sagen es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr
sehr krasse Erfahrung gewesen wie gut
aber das Essen wirklich ist weil darum
geht's uns natürlich heute das sehen wir
im heutigen Video das ganze hat
angefangen am Frankfurter Flughafen
[Musik]
es ist wirklich zu weit wir sitzen jetzt
hier es ist jetzt schon krank gewesen
also alleine in der Lounge was ankommen
hier der erste Drink wir sind beide noch
nie Business Class geflogen nein jetzt
machen wir es das alles hat mit der Idee
angefangen dass ich gerne mal das Essen
in der Business Class testen würde und
deshalb habe ich eine Mail bzw Philipp
mein Manager hat eine Mail an die
Lufthansa geschrieben und viele viele
Mail später war der Stand könnte
funktionieren dass unsere Tickets ge
upgradet werden aber wir erfahren es
erst am Schalter und ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich habe nicht allzu viel gehofft
deshalb volle Transparenz an der Stelle
wir haben das Upgrade bekommen das
normale Ticket haben wir gekauft jetzt
sitzen wir aber hier und es ist racy
also es ist eigentlich so dass man gar
nicht mehr anders will ne ich weiß nicht
manche von euch erinnern sich vielleicht
dann Moment wo ich das erstmal im
Sternerestaurant saß und auch die ganze
Zeit einfach nur gelacht habe zu dem
Zeitpunkt hat man noch nicht gesehen
genauso ist es also ich sag jetzt schon
das hat so nichts mit Fliegen zu tun
krass wir sitzen einfach auch so ein
super gemütlichen Sofa Sessel haben
unfassbar viel Stauraum wir haben
wirklich easy peasy alles neben uns
unter uns sonst wo verstaut ich habe das
Gefühl dieser Flug der elfeinhalb
Stunden lang sein wird ist wirklich den
Fingerschnipsen ja das ist natürlich
heute alles neben Sache klar wir ziehen
euch das weil wir haben diese Euphorie
gerade echt in uns aber wir werden uns
heute das Essen angucken das ist
natürlich auf unserem Channel das
wichtigste ich erzähle euch mal den ein
oder anderen Post gibt nach dem Start
und vor der Landung Menüs vor dem Start
haben wir die Auswahl als Vorspeise aus
einer konzierten Garnele auf Fenchel
Orangensalat mit grünem Mojo
oder Männer
mariniertes Black Angus Carpaccio mit
Kartoffel trüffelcreme Rucola und
Parmesan Tata von der Karotte mit
Meerrettichsoße eingelegten Gurken und
Brotchips die Hauptspeisen bitte einmal
von dir das war auch ein eigenes
Mikrofon aber ich möchte den hier machen
okay die Hauptspeisen sind einmal das
Backhendl mit Kartoffelsalat gebratenes
Lachs mit Zitronensoße und
marokkanischer Couscous Pasta oder die
steinpilzpasta mit Trüffel dazu
Nussbutter und Wurzelgemüse denkt
wirklich alles schon wieder viel zu
krank dann haben wir als Käse und bisher
einmal den längenvilla dorfkäse
montagnolo französischen ziegenweichkäse
mit Dattel sesam-honig Chutney Obatzter
und Trauben oder den bienenstift mit
gemischten Bären also wirklich das
klingt mehr als krass und das ist nur
das Menü das uns jetzt nach dem Start
erwartet sie liest sich auch wie
entweder ein sehr sehr gutes Restaurant
mindestens oder sogar ein
Sternerestaurant also es hat auf jeden
Fall schon es macht Hoffnung diese Karte
ich glaube es könnte richtig gut sein
wir haben die Auswahl zudem aus einer
Getränkekarte wo sich natürlich
Klassiker wie Softdrinks befinden Wasser
aber auch Champagner einfach mal hier so
ein paar tausend Meter über dem Boden
und rein saufen alles inklusive ne das
ist alles inklusive also all you can
drink wir treffen ne
wir haben natürlich trotzdem noch und
schwingt natürlich mit unserem Mädels
und finde Economy Class sitzen sind
quasi die modernen Gentleman aber in
Essen Style machen wir weil deshalb
haben wir auch die Korb und dann
tauschen wir auch mal mit denen wir ganz
genau wir zocken dann auch mal eine
Runde Mario Kart unten oder so das wird
sehr sehr krass ich bin unfassbar
gehyped auf den Flug und für mich hängt
der Urlaub gerade schon an das ist echt
so ja das ist nicht so dass wir gerade
nicht Reise das ist schon Urlaub gerade
das ist schon Erlebnis einfach gerade
wenn man zum ersten Mal macht so wie wir
beide deshalb großes Dankeschön danke
auch an euch dadurch dass ihr die Videos
schaut überhaupt so eine Möglichkeit
haben und jetzt lassen wir es uns gut
gehen oder das Essen kommt die Tische
sind nämlich hier in der Armlehne die
kann man sich einfach hier rausfahren
noch 10 Stunden Flugzeit ich bin schon
fast traurig dass es nur noch zehn sind
wir würden beim Champagner nehmen
Champagner muss ja sein und ich noch ein
Messerchen ich würde auch nur ein Wasser
nehmen vielen Dank kann man mal machen
oder ach wie herrliche prickelt oder ja
super
ich wollte schon hier dran trinken
gerade aus Gewohnheiten ich glaube da
kommt jetzt was an oh mein Gott danke
sehr danke schön ein ganzer Brotkorb hin
danke schön wir haben natürlich dieses
wunderbare Käsebrötchen wir haben ein
bisschen fancy Butter oben links mit so
einem schönen swirl drin und dann das
Carpaccio welches an der ein oder
anderen Ecke schon so ein bisschen
angetrocknet aussieht aber
nichtsdestotrotz sehr appetitlich
aussieht echtes Besteck aus Metall fühle
ich schon genauso wie die ganze Zeit aus
Glas trinken und nicht aus Plastik weißt
du was mir jetzt z.B schon direkt fehlt
bisschen Olivenöl klein bisschen Zitrone
und tröpfelchen Olivenöl wäre schon was
frei wir dürfen mich jetzt nicht bitte
rostet mich jetzt nicht in den
Kommentaren von wegen so ey der fliegt
Business Class der ist nicht zufrieden
ich meine jetzt aus nur Sicht wo man
alles sich wünschen könntet ihr so ein
bisschen vom karpaccio schöne
Cherrytomate bisschen Rucola der
perfekte Bike guten Appetit
ich glaube ich habe noch nie sowas
frisches in dem Flugzeug gegessen so
diese Tomate schmeckt so als würde ich
so vom Strauch kommen gerade das
Carpaccio hat so ein bisschen was von so
einem Luft getrockneten Schinken genau
wenn du mich fühlst ja was geschmacklich
überhaupt nicht verkehrt ist also
schmeckt sehr sehr lecker aber halt
weniger dann mit einem richtigen
Carpaccio zu tun das ist schon eher
Schinken wenn man so schon feststellen
ja würde ich auch sagen aber das ändert
nichts am Geschmack der sehr sehr gut
ist mariniertes Black Angus Carpaccio
mariniertes Carpaccio vielleicht ist das
deshalb auch so ein bisschen
angetrocknet gut dass wir noch mal
reinschauen mit Kartoffel trüffelcreme
das ist in diese kleinen Creme Häubchen
unter den Tomaten okay Rucola und
Parmesan diese Kartoffeln trüffelcreme
hat auch so eine citrusnote oder ja ich
mache jetzt noch mal den brottest Knigge
konform hier ein Stück abgerissen
mundgerecht ein bisschen von dieser
schönen Butter drauf
sehr lecker aber Crunch ist jetzt nicht
knack frisch vom Bäcker aber sehr sehr
lecker auch das ist auch schon eine Ecke
krasser als das was man unten bekommt
also no joke Vorspeise und das ist jetzt
genau das Ding auf welcher Skala
bewerten wir wie ist das für uns gerade
in diesem Flug in diesem Flugzeug liegt
so zwischen einer acht oder
siebeneinhalb von zehn glaube das Ding
ist warum wir es so bewerben weil es den
Anschein macht ganz normal zu sein um
das alles hier ist für uns als ob wir in
einem Restaurant werden und wir
vergessen nahezu dass wir eigentlich im
Flugzeug sind auch wie sich die Karte
gelesen hat das klingt so krass alles
der volle Fokus liegt gerade so auf
diesem Genuss anstatt auf dieser Reise
an sich man vergisst wirklich dass man
in der Luft ist einfach so ja weil man
sitzt ja auch gefühlt an einem
vollwertigen Tisch würde sagen das nach
achteinhalb von zehn experience ist 10
von 10 aber sowas von das ist wirklich
so ein Ding so wovon man so richtig
lange zehren kann was man so mitnimmt wo
man drüber nachdenkt was ein happy
machen abschließend zur Vorspeise anders
als erwartet sehr lecker und ein
gelungener Auftakt von zehn schauen wir
was uns als nächstes erwartet die
Hauptspeise ist angekommen sie wurde uns
wieder wunderbar serviert also wirklich
die ganze Crew hier ist auch super nett
fast so sehr wie ich mich auf mein
Backhendl freue ach sogar sowas ähnlich
wie Crunch hat auf der Oberfläche hier
drüben noch einen kleinen Kartoffelsalat
eine wichtige Zitrone für das Backhendl
oder wie man sagen möchte vielleicht
Hähnchenschnitzel lass uns das ganze
probieren
was aber ganz ähnlich wie bei Grubers
ist es der Geruch weil das riecht
wirklich so richtig nach so diesem
hähnchenstand vom Bauhaus so ein
bisschen krass und rein damit
das hat man schon beim Schneiden gemerkt
so butterweich schmeckt sehr lecker
so ein bisschen gezogener Kartoffelsalat
festkochende Kartoffeln der genau der
überraschend viel bis hat auch das ist
super lecker dem schmeckt wirklich alles
wieder ernst krass und ich muss höher
gehen mit der Bewertung gerade hatten
wir achteinhalb jetzt ist nur neun das
wäre eine zehn wenn das jetzt super
knusprig wäre dass die Panade super
knusprig wäre aber dadurch dass einfach
die technischen Gegebenheiten halt nicht
da sind du kannst es ja nicht Frittieren
okay backhandel wird natürlich gebacken
klar aber du kannst jetzt auch nicht 50
Minuten in den Ofen knallen hier ist das
fast perfekt und somit eine neue next ab
Bienenstich
[Musik]
wir haben gerade ein kleines Intro
bekommen wie das ganze funktioniert
Tatsache ist es gibt einfach nur
Öfen also alles was wir sehen wird in
einem Ofen zubereitet warm gemacht wie
auch immer und das ist tiefgefroren
dafür muss ich sagen dass auch ernst
solid ist der sieht jetzt so ernst
Industrie aus ja
okay erst wird super perfekt ja was soll
man zum Kuchen sagen schmeckt halt safe
nicht schlecht man merkt dass das so ein
wasserprodukte ich stell mir den sofort
wieder so so auf einem Quadratkilometer
so liegt und dann werden diese perfekten
Stücke geschnitten wir sind ja eh nicht
so die süßen zumindest rein kulinarisch
also das war's dann wohl von den ersten
drei Gerichten ich muss sagen optisch
solide geschmacklich waren wir beide
echt happy weil es einfach ganz nice
geschmeckt hat ob es jetzt am Szenario
lag ob es daran lag dass man in der Luft
anders schmeckt oder ob es einfach gut
war wir werden es niemals erfahren auf
jeden Fall hat es Spaß gemacht wir haben
auch noch keinen Vergleich genau wir
müssen weitere Business Class testen du
hast absolut Recht wir werden jetzt ein
wenig chillen vielleicht gleich mal ein
bisschen die Augen zu machen mal
runtergehen zu den Mädels guck mal das
alles machen das Ganze hier weiter
genießen du sagst es
[Musik]
sind wir wieder und noch besser gesagt
ist er schon die ganze Zeit
weitergegangen ja es sind jetzt etwa
sechs Stunden sieben Stunden acht
Stunden seit dem letzten Essen vergangen
nach dem Essen haben wir erstmal unseren
Sitz in die Horizontale gebracht haben
uns eine Schlafmaske geschnappt diese
sehr sehr gemütlichen Kissen in unserer
Nacken gelegt so auf die Seite gepackt
und erstmal eine Stunde einhalb wirklich
gemütlich gelegen so ernst geschlafen ja
wir haben mit unseren Mädels mit unseren
Freunden die Plätze getauscht waren für
ein paar Stunden in der Economy die Zeit
haben wir genutzt und haben ein paar
Runden Mario Kart gespielt wir haben
vegetarische Maultaschen mit einem
bisschen Tomate ein bisschen Spinat ein
wenig Joghurt mit Mandarine Grapefruit
würde ich sagen bisschen Granola und ich
habe eine Brezel eric hat ein Brötchen
das ist jetzt nur ein kleiner Snack also
das Hauptgericht die Hauptmahlzeit mit
drei Gängen hatten wir ja wie ihr
gesehen habt direkt nach Abflug einmal
schön rein
[Musik]
ich kann nichts sagen außer dass es mir
sehr gut schmeckt das Ding ist sind die
Nudeln perfekt aldentes safe nicht nein
schmeckt man irgendwelche pointierten
gewürzkontraste oder irgendwas heraus
auch nicht ist das ganze hier viel viel
geiler von der Erfahrung her als normal
zu fliegen ich konnte mich zu fliegen ja
Safe und ob ich mir das noch mal gönnen
würde wie wir das genau fanden das
erfahrt ihr jetzt
[Musik]
was soll ich sagen morgen ist es soweit
morgen fliegen wir zurück es war eine
sehr sehr schöne Zeit ihr werdet die
Videos dazu natürlich auch noch sehen
fliegen wir morgen Business Class nein
leider nicht also so ein Upgrade zu
kaufen einfach so mit Geld ist glaube
ich etwas für Leute die deutlich
deutlich mehr Geld haben als ich es habe
ich habe viele Leute die in der Business
Class sitzen kriegen das von
irgendwelchen Firmen mit denen Sie oder
für die sie arbeiten bezahlt da wäre ich
natürlich froh darüber wenn das noch mal
stattfinden könnte oder Leute holen das
mit Bonusmeilen aber ich würde auf jeden
Fall sagen dass es nicht das letzte Mal
war dass ich Business Class geflogen bin
freue mich aber auf Deutschland und wir
sehen uns aber aus Amer
[Musik]